Hey guys, we're back. What's going on. And if you, uh, if you, uh,
listen to the commercials, thanks so much, man. Could you help me back it up?
You know what I mean? No dunce anyway.
Uh.
No dance dude. No dance, right?
Insecure. So, um,
this is a trailer of a real movie called drunk parents.
Now I have not seen this trailer. I just know it's a movie. Why?
Because I travel on an airplane a lot of the time and every now and then you'll
look at the.
When you travel on an airplane and you see the movies that are sometimes,
you're like, Oh,
did they make these movies sincerely just for American airlines. Right?
That's what this is like. There's movies called drunk parents.
It's with Alec Baldwin and some highlights.
Now what all I can say is of course it's with them in it. Now. I like Alibaba.
When I'm, you know, I want to say, he's my buddy,
but I've done his show a few times. You know, I run into him. He's a good guy,
but this movie seems hilarious. I haven't looked at it yet.
I'm looking at it for the first time. So I don't know if we're going to have,
you know.
Wow. Cut out college girl. We're just a phone call away.
I love you guys so much. Thank you for everything.
Can I help you? I'm just doing my job. I just need a little more time.
Why don't we find a way to put some new lawsuits, sell some crap, Robin.
That's what's his day. Ma this is so boring so far.
I can't even believe that this is something to sell something. What is this kid?
Cuddy. Isn't a kid. Cudi. Cudi. I don't know.
My nickname. Salesforce crap. Robin. Why?
Sound sounds so bad. It's because it was, you know, I mean, if this,
if this was made anywhere, but Vancouver I'll straight up,
Rick rip one of my balls off. Oh, wow. I'll tell you why. It sounds so bad.
Okay. Nobody gives a. Oh yeah.
Nobody that made that movie gives a about anything. Sound guy goes like this.
They go like this. Did we get it? Sound? That goes like this?
Yeah, we got it. Let's go. Totally. Yeah. Oh yeah. We got it.
We about got it. That's what he said. Cause he's from Vancouver. Yeah. Break.
Alec Baldwin. Ever not wear that coat in a movie by the way. No,
it's always a gray double breasted with gloves.
I sorta got to be August in new Orleans. He's still wearing it finally.
Yeah. It was your money. I miss Donna's accountant. That was MasterCard.
Is this what the is this? What did he say?
I don't know. I don't know what the.
How is this? The beginning of a trailer. Okay. Okay. Okay. So,
so far what happened? Let's break down what happened.
So of course sweeping shot. So Vancouver. Okay. Yeah.
So she's.
Going to call her,
she's going to college they're together and they're leaving her to college and
he's wearing the coat. Okay.
So we're going go to every stirring the coat and she's always dressed for a
funeral for some reason. Right? Okay. So yeah.
Phone call away. I love you guys so much. And college kid, the interesting.
About the college cages. She's 34, right? So that's all good. Yeah.
So let's do this.
Thank you for everything.
That was by the way,
no humor or anything really in that, just, just exposition in a trailer,
which is crazy without that terrible music,
you would actually have no idea was supposed to be a comedy. Okay.
Can I help him? I'm just doing my job. I just need a little more time.
Why don't you find a way to put some new lawsuit? Salesforce, Brett, Robin,
finally a break.
Okay. So he's car gets towed. Why? I don't know.
He says I need a little bit more time. Right?
We don't know what that means for the car.
We don't know what that means for the movie at all.
And you definitely don't know what it means in relation to college or daughter
leaving a hundred percent. Okay. So, so, okay. So here we go.
Yeah. It was your money. Okay. Now he's talking on a phone,
but let's just go with an accent.
That was MasterCard.
Yeah. He was talking in an, in a phone,
on an act with an accent and his wife was watching him and she's still dressed
for a funeral. And how much did the dirt, by the way, he still has the jacket.
How much did the director beg him? Not to do the accent. And he said, okay.
And then did it like that every single time? Yeah. Oh, I won't do it. Oh,
you want me to, as a matter of fact, the director at the end,
he did nine takes under directors, like yeah. And he was like, uh, he was like,
did we get it? And then the director was like, sure. Cause you know, he's,
he's like, okay, he's not gonna do it. I told him not to do the accent. And I,
Bobby says, Oh wait, well, let's do one more.
Cause you said you wanted one without the accident. And there was a yeah.
And they said, and action. And he still did the accident. Okay.
So walked directly to his trailer. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. So,
and then what does he say here? That was Mr. Kurt. That was,
that was MasterCard. MasterCard master. That was mastered Mr. Kirk. Okay.
Papa daughter's accountant. That was MasterCard.
They're losing money. Okay. Going broke. They're going broke.
It's because it says they're going broke. Okay. I'm going.
To Nigel's for a minute. Okay.
Now Nigel is for sure British, come on. Now he's going into a wine cellar.
$800. Who's supposed to be looking after his property,
rent that out right out of his house. Rent house.
Nigel's house. That's the same.
There was a rental ad for this house on Craigslist.
Again, that's Jim Gaffigan.
I think he was sent from God as the new neighbor.
I'm legally required to tell you that I'm a registered sex
offender.
That's funny. I actually think that's funny. I think African's funny. Uh,
very weird. Very weird to go in this trailer.
Absolutely weird. Absolutely weird. The most benign trailer so far.
And now all of a sudden this guy's like I'm a sex offender, a new guy the only,
okay. Okay. So, and I'm not, I love golf again.
He's funny. This is my favorite part of the trailer Abloh site. Okay.
Sex offender come again. Wow. Really.
Pretty funny actually. Okay. As jokes go, he says, come again. That was funny.
Funny delivery. Alec Baldwin. Yeah. Paul was funny. He's funny. Yeah. Um, okay.
We gotta report a suspicious activity. Nigel.
How's it going over there in London? Huh?
I just had a conversation with the police. We're going to jail.
We gotta get outta here. Just take what you need for the next few weeks.
So I don't know. I'm lost.
So the renting the house out or no, there,
there are they're any the house that's Nigel's house. Yeah.
And Nigel is away is getting because he's away. And he heard the cops,
cops called him because something happened. Yes.
And they're renting out Nigel's house. Yes. So far has,
has nothing to do with drinking. Yeah.
It's not parenting drunk parents know or parenting. Yeah.
The kid goes away at college. Still. The movies should be called Nigel's house.
Yeah. So yeah. Well actually the,
probably the main problem I have with that is it shouldn't be called drunk
parents. I don't like titles like that. Right. It's like, it's just a blanket,
like bad teacher. Yeah. Yeah. Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. Cool.
Dad, I'll go. Frank and aunt Nancy are here. You two are welcome.
The bunk in the twins room.
Joe Minaj or whatever the. The hot guy. The haka is in it. The hot guy. Yeah.
The workout guy. Yeah. He was the hottest guy. What is up with this?
I get mistaken for him all the time. With what? D yeah.
What's the deal with this
movie? I don't D I mean, I have,
was it suppose it was definitely supposed to come out in the theaters. Yeah.
Alec Baldwin, Selma Hyatt, Jomo men, Juliano
mangenta yellow. I think. Um, uh, I mean,
kid Cuddy has a cameo. I'm sure. He's the cameo guy. And then the other guy,
Jim, Gaffigan's in it too. Yeah. These are big, big acts.
It doesn't look cheap either. It doesn't not don't think so. I mean,
it can't really be that cheap, but those people in it for true.
Hilarious, like Frank and I can overcome anything.
As long as we have to get
your mother to seems a little unhinged,
keep it close.
Those guys have booked those guys right there. I'm telling you right now.
I don't know this. Never seen him before.
I'm telling you they've booked over 110 commercials. I mean,
look at those two guys.
Those guys have done so many commercials where they go like this. Um, yeah.
They make the face. Yeah. Yeah. Have you talked about the face? No.
You should talk about the, we'll talk about the face after this.
That's fine.
Stop the truck. Wayne, throw a rocket.
You probably caught him all it.
How are you? I'm on the right side of the grasp of man.
What's the Habs.
What is it called? They're not even drinking in it.
What's the hats that made me mad when he said it
don't like that at all. You don't like that. Why not? Butters? Isn't in sell.
Why don't you like that?
I just not into like ending the trailer on what's ending it on that as bad yet.
It's not good. Yeah. Uh, yeah. They're not drinking once in that. No,
not even a little bit. So that's a weird thing.
They might as well call it the avatar six or some. It's not that either. Um,
so anyway, uh, the face, yeah. You haven't talked about no,
I haven't actually it's um, every, every, uh,
movie poster has this face on it. Every comedy has his face on it. Yeah.
It's like this, right. It's and it's 99% of the time. It's a guy.
Yeah. It's also girls now it's equal. You know what I mean?
Now there's 2019 girls.
Now you're making me sound sexist when it comes to the face. But every comedy,
but look up anyone, look up. Any comedy posters, look up. Anyone with Tim Allen,
especially sitcoms TV. Comedy is the most, most like,
look at this situation I'm in right now. How I got myself into hi-jinks. Right,
right. Catch you later. They all do. And all do an immersion.
Those guys are doing that awkward moment.
Knocked up. Look at the knocked up one. That's I mean, he's stand up,
scroll up there. There you go. That's the face to a tee. You almost got some,
I just know. Cause he wasn't scrolling up and I want him to scroll up to it.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah. That's the most. Yeah. I don't know what it is.
It's you know what it is? Cause I've done sitcoms and.
It's hard to not do the face. And if you do it once they got it,
that's the one they're gonna use. I look at, Oh, look it.
You're good to go to bed. Go to your, go, go,
go back to the one you just said good. The Justin Timberlake. I'm getting past,
I'm getting. Go back to Justin Timberlake one. You just had. Wow. Just go back.
And I'm friends with benefits, dude, Justin Timberlake.
Right now the thing is Justin Timberlake is just making the face because he's a
singer and he's like, Oh, this is the face that actors do. Yeah. What,
but that's the thing though. People, uh, people, uh,
like when you're shooting the for the stuff,
cause they did it for the sitcom and they were like, Hey, you know, what's up,
what's up now? How'd you get yourself in this position? Like, they'll do that.
And you'd be like, I don't know. And then, and you're like. And then you're.
Yeah. So anyway, go see drunk parents.
All you have to do is take a flight somewhere. You can't. Yeah.
There's nowhere to see it. Yeah. Uh, that reminds me of that movie.
I did a fake, totally worse than death though.
That's why I say it's in Vancouver. Oh wow.
The other day was an Aaron and then yes, Aaron. Paul was in it.
That's how we became friends. Anyway. That's what, that's what it is
to take another break. Let's take another break. Okay.
And then we'll be right back.